we got things to talk about what you
need today begins in in South Florida
where the NFLPA meetings are ongoing and
chaos has unfolded for the Players Union
in recent days look they're in the
middle of voting on a new labor deal and
the window opened last Thursday it's now
been extended to Saturday night at 11:59
p.m. Eastern that was one of the
decisions made yesterday by the 32
member Board of player representatives
but look it's obvious that something is
afoot here that there's some effort
there's some plan that previously had
been in the shadows to take down
executive director - Morris Smith and
one thing that encouraged me yesterday
and I applaud Russell o kun for doing
this he has stepped out of the shadows
and into the light with his fight
against Tamura Smith he filed a claim
with the National Labor Relations Board
accusing his union of bad faith
negotiation tactics as relates to how
this deal with the NFL was negotiated
and ultimately pushed through the
various levels of approvals and
advancement within the NFLPA and look
I'm not gonna get into any of the
niceties here the bottom line is Oakland
is standing up and saying that demora
Smith and also Eric Winston the outgoing
as of today NFL PA president have
handled their business improperly and
the NLRB needs to look into it and I
like that Chris not not that I'm saying
that he's right that anything should
happen right but for days now I've been
telling you
look this vote isn't simply about
sticking it to the league this also is
going to stick it to the man who you
have hired to run the Union and I'm glad
that somebody is finally calling it that
so the players as they continue to vote
understand what a no vote means and
understand what a yes vote means yeah
well I mean it's interesting nonetheless
first off you've been all over the
russell o Kuhn stuff and his play to
become the NFLPA president but here's
what I don't get and maybe you can
explain to me a little bit more you know
one of the things you talked about like
pushing the deal through right was the
deal and I felt at the time that this
was kind of swiped under the rug but was
the deal not even supposed to be pushed
forward because it did not pass with the
executive committee
do I have that right or were they still
able to push that forward go ahead
that's one of the arguments Russell o
Kuhn is making cuz here's what happened
I jump down to me Mike and I'd never we
never really digested that or dove into
what really went on there this is what
happened in Indianapolis what we did
dive into it you were done this is a
very serious topic if we're making fun
of you having on the air 13 days ago
anyway what happened was the executive
committee with Dee Smith involved in the
process negotiated this deal with the
league and it was astounding to me and
Chris we first caught wind of it at the
Super Bowl right when Richard Sherman a
member of the executive committee
chastised the media for not pointing out
the hypocrisy of the NFL wanting to play
17 games and also wanting to preserve
player health and safety and you and I
both very passionately said Richard
you're on the executive committee you
guys have been negotiating based on 17
games from months right so look hey
let's find out exactly what was going on
was D Smith negotiating this thing and
not telling the executive committee that
they were negotiating based on 17 games
what happened here and when the
executive committee decides they reject
the deal that they negotiated what is
the proper step under the NFLPA
Constitution and should the process have
ended there should they have gone back
to the league and said sorry the group
that negotiated this deal with you no
longer believes that this is the right
deal and we need to engage in further
negotiation but you know and and this is
where and I'm not saying somebody's
right that somebody's wrong but this is
where it gets interesting and where
reasonable Minds can differ on whether
it was handled properly should D Smith
have continued to push it through to the
full board of player representatives for
a vote that barely got enough of a
majority to allow this vote to happen by
the full union so Louis yeah so what do
you got there so like the bylaws of the
the CBA Constitution would say that you
don't push that forward right so it's
unclear it's okay it's unclear right
it's open it's open to interpretation
and the board of player representatives
have the power to interpret under
Article five of
NFLPA Constitution they have the power
to interpret the Constitution that's the
32 member Board of player represented
right so look here's the thing
however this all shakes out it's useful
to all players to be aware of the fact
that what's really going on here is an
effort by some to oust Dee Smith because
I think the effort private prior to this
was let's not really call it what it is
let's just tell the players vote no and
let's tell the players vote no because
voting know is given the middle finger
to the billionaires who are trying to
run our lives not voting no means we're
saying we have no confidence in the man
who's been the executive director of the
Union for the last 11 years and now he's
got to go see that's the next logical
step if they vote no yes if this CBA
doesn't pass it's time to get somebody
else to run the Union because the guy
who's running the Union negotiated a
deal that the players have rejected so
now now it's out there that's what I
like about this let's get it out there
so the players understand and if they
want to make a change make a change I
didn't like the idea that there were
some who were trying to call this
something that it wasn't in order to
lead to an outcome that the players
maybe didn't realize they were signing
on for now everybody knows yes that's
why I applaud Russell oku now will he be
the NFLPA president probably not and he
may have gone forward with this Chris
once it dawned on him I'm not gonna get
17 votes from the 32 member Board of
player representatives because they know
I hate the deal and 17 of them voted for
the Dia's so how will 17 ever vote for
me so this may have been his fallback
plan that he intended to do all along
but either way I'm just I'm encouraged
by the fact that we now know what's
going on and we can now hash it out and
we can now figure out and the Union it's
not our business it's for the Union to
figure out whether or not they want this
CBA and whether or not they want to
continue to be led by D Smith okay so
how much longer does this go now with
the NLRB or did I say that right I think
I did how to cite it how does how does
that go now with making this filing to
them how long will it be till we hear
till that maybe there was or wasn't mal
practices involved in this and D Maurice
Smith D Maurice Smith you know pushing
this forward without the proper consent
of the players how long will this take
well look at the NLRB does not move
quickly on anything they've got plenty
of work to do and they're not gonna stop
everything they're doing to get involved
now to derail a vote that has been
extended from Thursday night at 11:59
p.m. Eastern to Saturday night at 11:59
p.m. Eastern and we'll know Sunday
morning whether or not the CBA passes
now if the CBA fails this thing kind of
becomes irrelevant because the other
processes I've talked about gets set in
motion d.smith quite possibly will be
out new executive director new president
voted on today new leadership for the
Union but if the vote passes and the CBA
goes forward then you're gonna have this
weird reality where you've got a CBA in
place between the league in the union
but you're gonna have this ongoing fight
either in front of the National Labor
Relations Board or I suspect at some
point some sort of a law suits gonna be
filed right
Russell o kun is working with a lawyer
here why wouldn't he be to put these
paperwork's together and get this thing
moving but there could be some sort of
litigation that challenges what the
NFLPA is done and tries to blow up the
CBA after the CBA is in force so look I
have never researched these questions of
what can and can't be done to defeat a
CBA once it's signed off on and once
it's actually implemented yeah but I
think that's what Russell o king is
trying to do so the fight will continue
whether it's successful or not it's
going to continue after Sunday morning
when we know whether or not there's a
new CBA again if there isn't a new CBA
it's moot if there is a new CBA then
there may be this ongoing fight to try
to blow it up retroactively things have
we really heard what roasts Russell o
kun doesn't like about the CBA okay and
the other thing too maybe you could
answer this maybe I missed this on my
puke day okay but do we know anything
more
as far as why do we know anybody else on
the Executive Committee like Richard
Sherman who seems to be uninformed that
there was you know 17 games in the CBA
negotiation talks did we I don't know
right okay we seem to know though right
okay but here's the thing here's the
thing 6 to 5 was the vote of the 11
person Executive Committee against the
CBA two weeks ago
so there are six of the eleven who are
against this now what do they say about
when they were told it's 17 games what
leverage what what negotiation happened
what was done yeah I look there's a
story to be told by each member of the
Executive Committee as to exactly what
happened like I can understand that that
yeah and and I feel like Dee Smith is
trying to stay above the fray and all of
this yeah there's a certain point where
the fray is on your front porch and you
have to engage I said last hour on radio
if you're in a bar and a couple of guys
are fighting and you're a spectator on
the other side of the bar and you don't
want to get involved in it that's fine
they roll in your direction there's a
point where you got no choice Yeah right
you've got to jump into it and and I
feel like Dee Smith if the time has come
for him to jump into this because I know
now look I I don't know maybe at this
point it's too late to do anything
the vote is either gonna be yes or no
and if the votes no then the dominoes
fall in one very specific way and I
think they're finding a new executive
director and if the votes yes he's still
gonna have to I think fend off some of
these guys who were gonna be coming at
him but it's a lot easier if a majority
of the Union has said we want this new
CBA and we're moving forward with it
well yes and you know the other thing
I'll just say just as a guy who I didn't
sit here and you know read the the the
new contract or anything like that you
know I've read little excerpts here and
there but just more or less listening to
the pliers this is what I'll just say
that stands out to me more than anything
the the naysayers the people who want to
say no don't vote no I just haven't had
a lot of good reasons on why to vote no
I thought that would be I you know I've
heard a little rush you know right right
here's the two things no 17 games that
should have been a non-starter that
should have been a point of negotiation
we should have always been negotiating
on a 16-game season we should have stood
firm on no 17 games the problem is the
owners were just as firm if not firmer
and it would have gone all the way into
a potential lockout next year if the
players had said we're not going to
negotiate based on 17 games but the
Aaron Rodgers argument is we're not
getting enough there's other stuff we
can get that doesn't cost them anything
like reducing the offseason program and
Rodgers would likely to be reduced to
nothing so
that's really I think the more common
argument we haven't gotten enough for
agreeing to play 17 games and that's why
I've been saying for the last week Chris
that the guy who runs the union has
exercised his judgment that it is enough
that you're maximizing the size of the
slice of the pie you're getting and by
doing the deals now you're maximizing
the size of the total pie because the TV
deals are going to follow the new CBA
you either accept his judgment or you
don't and if you don't then get a new
executive director that's why I'm so
glad that this effort by Russell wrote
oak whom is pushing into the light
what's really going on here the guys who
are saying no to the CBA are as a
practical matter saying no to D Smith
and the players as they cast their
ballots need to understand that and if
they want to do that do it pull the pin
on their glasses you need to understand
that that's what you're doing why did we
move it back two days I don't know if
I've read anything on on the website or
anywhere else there well why it was put
back two days and again I'm not in the
weeds on this subject and I know you
certainly are but do we know why the
volca pushed back 48 hours I don't know
whether it's a case where not enough
guys have voted oh we don't know I don't
know whether it got you know what you
know what it may be here's my guess
here's my guess right because yesterday
the NFLPA put out a sheet that compares
details of the last CBA to the new CBA
and the and I guess the thought is
they're just getting this now let's give
them more time to vote because they can
now digest this instead of reading the
456 page document the problem is some
guys want to change their votes now and
the board of player representatives
voted yesterday not to let them do it
although I'd like to think it's fairly
easy to do because it was all electronic
it's not like busting open the ballot
box and say hey this is my X on this
sheet of paper I'm gonna change it from
no to yes so I think that that that you
look there's a haphazard quality to this
the D Smith's gonna have to answer for
at some point as well and maybe he's
gonna answer for it at the ballot box
maybe there's no vote if it happens to
be no is going to end up being a
referendum on him and they go back to
the bargaining table with a new
executive director whether that's good
or bad for the Union remains to be seen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports